foreign
thank you
so
much
Excellence is
their colleagues
ladies and gentlemen
oh
I wish to propose
that we
first engage in
consultations brief consultations
before we start the meeting
is that agreeable
to you
I hope that
our exchange of views will be short
and then we will come back to the room
and then start our meeting and continue
is that acceptable to you
yes I see there is agreement in that
thank you so much for your understanding
foreign
thank you
good morning
completely
foreign
because we were talking about
thank you
foreign
[Music]
and 86th meeting
of the security Council
is called to order
the provisional agenda
for this meeting
is
maintenance of peace and security
of Ukraine
the agenda is adopted
in accordance with the rule 37
of the council's provisional rules of
procedure
I invite
the representatives
of Denmark
Lithuania
and Ukraine
to participate in this meeting
it is so decided
in accordance with rule 39
.
of the council's provisional rules of
procedure
I invite
Mr Martin Griffiths under Secretary
General
for humanitarian affairs
an emergency
relief coordinator
to participate
in this meeting
it is so decided
in accordance
with the rule 39
of the council's provisional rules or
procedure
I propose
to invite
Miss Maria Daria
morozova
to participate
in this meeting
who they remember wish to comment on
this proposal
yes I recognize
the representative
of the United States
thank you Mr President
the United States requests a procedural
vote on the participation of Miss
morzova as a proposed briefer for this
meeting
we regret having to call this vote given
that the majority of council members
already Express serious concerns to the
presidency yesterday and today
let me be clear the United States
strongly supports Civil Society briefers
who can share their relevant experience
and expertise with the council
the perspectives of Civil Society
participants are essential and they
enrich this council's discussion
however we must note that a certain
council member proposed the addition of
Ms marzova as and I quote an ombus
person of the donasked People's Republic
following the Russian federation's
attempt last year to illegally Annex
Ukraine's internationally recognized
territory the U.N General Assembly
overwhelmingly adopted resolution ESS 11
4. this resolution specifically called
on all states an international
organizations to not recognize any
alteration of the status of the Donas
region of Ukraine and to refrain from
any dealings that might be interpreted
as recognizing any such altered status
consistent with that U.N General
Assembly resolution it is not
appropriate for the council to invite in
any capacity someone who purports to be
the ombus person of the so-called don't
ask People's Republic
the invitation to this specific person
is a blatant and transparent attempt to
have the council appear to legitimize
the Russian federation's illegal
attempted annexation and to implicitly
extend recognition to illegitimate
authorities
simply removing references to their
positions or their titles does not alter
this fact council members can and should
draw their own conclusions about any
attempts to draw reductionist parallels
to other incomparable situations
we regret that a procedural vote is
necessary we call on all council members
to act consistent with relevant U.N
General Assembly resolutions and not
support the proposed briefers
participation in the meeting today the
United States will not support any
attempt to legitimize the Russian
federation's illegal attempted
annexation of another U.N member States
Territory and will therefore vote no and
urge others to do the same thank you Mr
President
I think
the representative
of the United States
for they are
a statement
I
now give the follow to the
representative of the Russian Federation
we insist on the participation of the
debriefer invited today for today's
meeting
our delegation has introduced the
proposal to invite Daria marozova Guided
by a single consideration that being to
provide the council with an opportunity
to receive first-hand information about
the catastrophic humanitarian situation
in that region which
in donbass which was inextricably linked
to the humanitarian situation in Ukraine
the residents have done boss since 2014
have been forced to survive under the
shelling of the Ukrainian armed forces
have been forced to endure deprivations
in the complete absence of any reaction
whatsoever on the part of the
International Community this is an issue
which our Western colleagues have been
scrupulously sidestepping which is in
line with their policy to whitewash any
Crimes by Kiev regardless of how
abhorrent they may be the briefer
proposed by us is arrest as a native of
Dunbar she spent her entire life in that
region and since 2014 she has been
engaged in active humanitarian
activities helping her fellow countrymen
and women who have been suffering from
aggression by Kiev that she has been
dealing with among other things hostage
swapped previously participating in the
work of the contact group on the
implementation of the Minsk agreements
her experience and her expertise are
unique Daria every day in engages with
ordinary people in dunbas and she is
willing to share the observations her
observations which will provide the
council with an overview of the real
situation on the ground
we believe that our briefer fully meets
the criteria set out in rule 39 of the
council's provisional rules of procedure
we propose that she be heard in her her
personal capacity as a humanitarian
activist we call on the council
membership to support the invitation to
Daria marozova in the capacity as
briefer during today's meeting contrary
to allegations of Western delegations
your support will in no way indicate the
recognition of any International legal
realities whatsoever these are issues
that are completely unrelated
this is also a matter of freedom of
speech at the moment we are talking
merely about an invitation of a
competent briefer for the council to
receive additional information about the
humanitarian situation as it set out in
rule 39. otherwise today's meeting will
become yet another
one-sided Western event which ignores
the root causes of the Ukrainian crisis
thank you
I thank
the representative of the Russian
Federation
for their statement
I now give the flow to the
representative of Albania
thank you Mr President
the purpose of this meeting is to draw
attention to of the council to the dire
humanitarian situation in Ukraine caused
by Russia's aggression and flagrant
transgression of international law
three resolutions of the general
assembly adopted with an overwhelming
majority of member states have made it
clear that Russian Federation is in
blatant violation of the U.N Charter and
international law and is responsible for
the humanitarian crisis in Ukraine and
beyond that Russia should withdraw from
Ukraine and respect Ukraine's
sovereignty and territorial integrity
the arrests they want to shoot today by
ICC against Russia's commander-in-chief
only affirms this responsibility
it is clear once again
that with the attitude of today the
Russian Federation is trying to do what
it does best divert the focus of the
issues at hand avoid responsibility by
its action by creating small screen
this is yet another diploma deplorable
attempt to misuse the council for narrow
interests other than the resonate of
this body
further with the invitation Russia is
rubbing salt into the wound by inviting
a representative that it of the
so-called donesk's people Republic in a
desperate attempt to legitimize what can
never be legitimized the invasion and
the annexation of by force of a
territory of another solving country
while reaffirming our unwavering
commitment to giving unhindered success
to Civil Society briefers in the work of
the council we reiterate our position
that the Russian Federation attitude is
a deviation from this principle to allow
the participation of an illegal entity
in the council meeting would be a
dangerous precedent
hence would not consider the brief
proposed by the Russian Federation
competent to the purpose at hand has
stipulated in rule 39 of the security
Council provisional rules of procedure
Albania therefore opposes extending
invitation by the council to the
additional briefer proposed by the
Russian Federation and we kindly ask the
other members of
member states of the council to do the
same vote no thank you
I thank the representative
of Albania for their statement
distinguished members
of the council
in light of the comments made
by the council members
I propose to put to vote to the vote
uh the proposal to extend an invitation
under rule 39 of the councils
provisional rules of procedure
to Mrs Daria morozova
in order to brief the security Council
under gender item
maintenance of peace and security
of Ukraine
I shall put the proposal
to the vote
now
at the request of the Russian Federation
I will repeat
the
what I said
previously
and I quote myself
in light
of the comments made
by the council members
I propose
to put to the vote
The Proposal
to extend an invitation
under rule 39
of the council's
provisional rules of procedure
to miss
Daria morozova
in order to brief the security Council
under agenda
item
maintenance
of peace and security
of Ukraine
I give
the floor to the representative
of the Russian Federation
ah yes
Mr person could you please specify which
vote means what
yes or no
those willing
uh
those in favor
of The Proposal
to extend
an invitation
will vote Yes
those against
extending
an invitation
to miss Daria
morozova will vote no
those abstaining will abstain
foreign
shall we proceed
okay
so we shall start now
those
against
oh no don't sorry sorry those in favor
of extending the invitation
please
raise their hand
is that clear
those
against
obsessions
so the result of the voting
is
as follows
four votes in favor
eight votes
against
and the three
abstentions
The Proposal
to invite
Miss Daria
morozova
has not been adopted
it having failed
to obtain
the required number
of votes
I will
give the floor to the representative of
the Russian Federation
Mr President
we regret the fact that a number of
delegations today spoke out against
voted against having the invitation
extended to the briefer we see in this
manifestation of egregious hypocrisy and
double standards one representative of
donpass has for 10 for nine years been
suffering as a result of this war
Unleashed by Kiev against it it has been
refused under trumped-up pretexts to
enjoy the right to speak before the
security Council
this merely confirms the fact that you
do not view the residents of dunbasa's
people and you have no concern
whatsoever about their suffering our
Western colleagues are afraid that if
the voices of Truth pave the way all of
their efforts to whitewash their
subordinates in key of will collapse
attempts to avoid this uh you know they
have to avoid this they've been adopted
any procedural trivia with a menial
unscrupulous Endeavor which is
completely
unconscientious and base I wish to
underscore that we have never gone down
to this level when our Western
colleagues proposed a briefer for a
meeting on russophobia which we convened
we did not object even though his
so-called briefing was
abounded with
mendacious lies in traditional Western
narratives
there was no constructive contribution
to the contribution to the discussion
that was made by this briefer ultimately
what happened today with Daria merlosova
is an opportunity for us to think about
how we would consider requests from
colleagues on rule 39 moving forward
our U.S colleague said that listening to
briefers from auchen recognized
territories is unacceptable and
constitutes a violation of a resolution
but for example the invitation of
Representatives of Kosovo to the council
this is a clear violation of Security
Council resolution
1244. we will take into account the
principal position of our U.S colleagues
on that count
otherwise we will see further double
standards from the United States
we regret the fact that the work of the
council once again has fallen Hostage to
the unscrupulous conduct of Western
delegations who are openly seeking to
advance their parochial interests thank
you
I thank
the representative
of the Russian Federation
for their
statement
I
now give the floor
to the distinguished representative
of Albania
thank you Mr President and I'll be very
brief but um
I'm regret to take the floor again but
after having heard the Russian
delegation I need just to put the
records straight because it is very
important
um comparing the two realities that have
have not nothing absolutely nothing in
in common is absolutely artificial the
prefabricated so-called donesque
Republic a territory of Ukraine
illegally annexed by Russia and the
Republic of Kosovo have absolutely
nothing in common it is regrettably not
the first time but when you are in so
much dry you try
do I need to remind our Russian
colleagues that icj issued advisory
opinion stating that the Declaration of
Independence of course have adopted in
2000 into 1008 did not did not violate
the international law the very World
Court that has also issued another
opinion in March last last year and we
know why
do I need to remind our Russian
colleagues that kosovo's International
recognition is well established
including among many around this table
while the so-called DPR and LPR are
territories annexed by force and exist
only in the Russian plans and dreams and
finally I do not need to remind the
Russian colleagues that Kosovo and
Serbia come here together
and they are negotiating to find
mutually agreed solutions to common
problems not with bombs not but with
words not with war but with dialogue
this is the big difference as well thank
you
I think
the representative of Albania for their
statement
I give the flow to the representative of
the Russian Federation
Mr President uh just heard
and I listened to the emotional
statement of our Albanian colleague
about the presence of Serbia during
meetings under resolution 24 12 44. we
have nothing against that however I'd
like to put forward a question to him
perhaps he will
take the opportunity to respond to the
question here in this chamber tell us
please do you view Kosovo as a territory
recognized by the United Nations
I think
the representative of the Russian
Federation
for their statement
excellencies distinguished members of
the council
in accordance with the rule 39
all the council's provisional rules of
procedure
I also invite
his Excellency Mr wolof's cook
head of the delegation of the European
Union to the United Nations
to participate in this meeting
so decided
the security Council
will now begin
its consideration
of item two of the agenda
I now give the floor
to Mr Martin Griffiths
you have the floor sir
Mr President thank you very much
when I spoke to this Council
about the situation in Ukraine last
month
I highlighted the humanitarian impact
of the full-scale war
a year since it started
I spoke then of the death destruction
and hardship
it has inflicted and continues so to do
upon the people of Ukraine
I shared facts about the casualties
cause the families bereaved
homeless
and destitute
that two out of every five people in
Ukraine are in need
of assistance to survive
the people forced to flee including more
than eight million refugees
in neighboring countries
but Mr President today
if you allow me
I want to focus
on the reverberations around the world
of this war
a world already reeling
before that date
in February from multiple shocks
hunger conflict
covid
climate emergency the cost of living
crisis
Mr President the war has had very
significant implications for Global Food
insecurity
as we all know both the Russian
Federation and Ukraine
are leading suppliers
of key food commodities
and in addition the Russian Federation
is also a top exporter
of fertilizer
the world relies on these supplies and
has done so for many years
and so do does the United Nations
getting its help for those in need
the world food program sources much of
the wheat for the global humanitarian
response each year
from Ukraine
last February
when shipping operations were suspended
from Ukrainian ports in the Black Sea
the Ripple effects were immediate
by March
following uninterrupted increases from
the second half of 2020
Global food prices
reached record highs
the price of fertilizer
has been impacted
Gravely and remains still over 200 times
higher
than in 2019
in lower income countries some small
farmers found themselves priced out of
the market
reversing these Trends as we may all
remember was a matter of urgency for the
International Community
hence the Black Sea grain initiative
and the parallel memorandum
of understanding between the Russian
Federation
and the United Nations
on the facilitation in this second
agreement
of Russian food and fertilizer exports
the signing of those agreements
was a critical step in the broader fight
against Global Food insecurity
especially in developing countries
as a result
markets have been calmed
and yet dope and Global food prices have
indeed continued to fall
under the Black Sea grain initiative
close to 25 million metric tons of fruit
stuffs have been safely exported without
incident from Ukraine since August
the world food program has been able to
transport
more than half a million metric tons of
wheat to support humanitarian operations
in Afghanistan
Ethiopia Kenya Somalia
and Yemen
and right now the United Nations under
the leadership of our Secretary General
between everything possible
to make sure that that Black Sea grain
initiative
can continue
we continue to engage closely with all
parties
this week
foodstuffs have continued to be
transported out of Ukraine through those
Maritime humanitarian corridors and
under the oversight of that agreement
joint coordination Center in Istanbul
on the parallel memorandum of
understanding with the Russian
Federation
by colleague the Secretary General of
Untied Rebecca Greenspan and the U.N
Secretary General himself
are together sparing no effort to
facilitate its full
implementation
we have indeed made meaningful progress
impediments remain however notably with
regard
to Payment Systems there is a lot more
to do
and our efforts to overcome
these remaining imperative impediments
will continue Mr President
elevated
it is vital
for Global Food security that both of
these agreements continue
and should be fully implemented
Mr President of the world
faces an unstable global economy of a
team
is growing and when we look at where we
want to be
the targets we set out
in the sustainable development goals it
is so clear
that we are way off track
the scale of humanitarian needs as
discussed frequently in this chamber Mr
President
is vastly outpaced the resources
available to meet those needs
globally
almost 347 million people
in 69 countries
need humanitarin Aid
a statistics so dire it hardly Bears
repetition
an unprecedented 54 billion dollars is
required this year to meet these needs
and millions will suffer if we fail to
do that
in 2022
member states made significant financial
estimate efforts excuse me
to meet the growth in needs
as total humanitarian funding the
generosity of many many member states
reached a historic High
of just under 39 billion dollars
we cannot be certain
if this level of financing can be
achieved this year
while it is similarly clear that we need
even more support than that
from Member States from the public
from a generous Humanity
so that we can deliver on that most
sacred promise
to protect the vulnerable and to provide
a future for them and their families
we also need closer collaboration
between humanitarian and development
communities
and international financial institutions
together we must seek Sustainable
Solutions the provision of basic
Services which can be relied on by
families across Nations
Sustainable Solutions to the probability
for us to those spiraling humanitarian
needs to which I have referred
to the debt crisis
to the convergence of other problems
on the horizon
our neighbors but one Somalia
of which we have often spoken in this
chamber faces an extraordinary and
unprecedented and tragic failure of a
sixth season
more than ever
in this context
do we need a political solution to the
war in Ukraine
the people of Ukraine deserve peace
first and foremost
they deserve to turn the page on this
terrible War has to be all
Mr President I thank you
I thank Mr Griffiths for his briefing
I will now give the floor to those
council members
who wish to make statements
I'll give the fall to the representative
of Ecuador
Gracia thank you Mr President
before
referring to the substantive issue which
has brought us to this meeting today I
wish to make it patently clear that
Ecuador voted against the proposal to
include as a briefer
murasova bearing in mind the original
request of the Russian Federation to
have her participate in an Institutional
capacity
on the part of a so-called People's
Republic that my country does not
recognize or will never recognize
moreover with its vote Ecuador
facilitated the implementation of
resolution es
11-4 of the 11th emergency special
session of the general assembly convened
by the decision of this very Security
Council with resolution
the resolution of the 27th of February
2022 Ecuador's vote does not preempt our
position of openness when it comes to
including both male and female briefers
or various types
suggested by various delegations
regardless of their original political
position and incidentally
and that including any territory under
total or partial occupation Mr President
I sank under Secretary General of
humanitarian Affairs and coordinator of
emergency assistance Mr Martin Griffiths
for his briefing
I also thank
Ocha
and the team on the ground for their
invaluable work
on the 6th of February in the briefing
on the humanitarian situation in Ukraine
Ecuador concluded its statement
recognizing the contribution made by the
Black Sea grain initiative in
alleviating the global consequences of
food insecurity
at that time we called for this Council
to reiterate its support for the work of
the Secretary General and to ensure that
that support was tangible and effective
we believe that the renewal of the Black
Sea grain initiative must be automatic
and without hindrance just like its
implementation today with 24 hours to go
until the 120 days elapsed before the
renewal of the agreement should take
place I wish to focus on this Central
Point echoing the words of the Secretary
General Antonio Gutierrez when
he said that the grain initiative was a
Beacon of Hope possibility and relief
in the session
held on the 17th of March 2022 exactly a
year ago USG DiCarlo warned of the
consequences that the conflict was
already having at that time across the
world as a whole these consequences were
dealing the heaviest blow to the poor
because Supply chains were disrupted and
the food price index of the FAO had been
brought to the highest levels ever seen
in history as the host of the fowl
Regional Conference in Quito in March
last year Ecuador can ensure that at
that time and indeed this remains true a
fundamental concern for Latin American
and the Caribbean is the impact that
this war is having beyond the borders of
the country under attack
whilst grain exports Are Not Alone
food Aid operations they continue to
play a vital role in alleviating food
insecurity and consequently in
alleviating the humanitarian situation
in various regions of the world
behind this tragedy that is war the
implementation of the grain initiative
has worked to spare millions of lives
from Hunger this is particularly true in
fragile areas and it did so because it
stabilized prices indeed that has been
confirmed by on several occasions by the
FAO and even the United Nations
conference on trade and development
here we should add that the initiative
is having an impact within the framework
of wfp operations these are benefiting
girls and boys in Afghanistan Yemen
Somalia or Ethiopia to name but a few
these operations must not be disrupted
nor must the wfp's capacities be
undermined
we know that currently we have scheduled
three
wfp vessels they will transport 80 000
metric tons of wheat wheat and that is
scheduled in the midst of all of this
uncertainty being sparked by the process
by which this agreement will be renewed
and that uncertainty is prevailing
despite the fact the renewal is meant to
be automatic Mr President in only two
months we will Mark the fifth
anniversary of resolution 2417 with that
resolution the council urged all parties
to guarantee the proper functioning of
food systems and food markets in
situations of armed conflict with that
same resolution the council recalled the
link that exists between armed conflicts
and food insecurity it insisted that all
parties protect civilians
and the goods and property necessary for
the production and distribution of food
Ecuador consequently insists upon the
need to respect Food Systems and water
supply systems we recall the prohibition
that there is
against attacking destroying removing or
spoiling property and objects crucial to
the survival of civilians that includes
agricultural goods and harvests moreover
we are not surprised by but we are
concerned by the findings published by
the fowl last December regarding the
impact that this war is having on
agriculture and Rural livelihoods in
Ukraine
tens of thousands of Millions
of harvest Sabine loss of
wealth is being lost by homes we're
seeing the destruction of machinery and
equipment as well as storage facilities
crops inputs and arable land we regret
the fact that in 2023 so far we've seen
the repeated continuation of attacks
against critical civilian infrastructure
this includes energy infrastructure
finally and by way of a preliminary
comment I wish to express the fact that
my delegation is Gravely concerned at
the content of the report of the
international independent Commission of
inquiry in Ukraine established pursuant
to resolution 49 1 of The Human Rights
Council that report was distributed
yesterday and it
paints a picture of the cruelest
violations of humanitarian law human
human rights rather and points to Human
Rights abuses and the most atrocious
violations of IHL Ecuador will never tie
in reiterating the fact that nothing
exempts parties from complying with
obligations under the Geneva conventions
of 1949 or the or other core instruments
of IHL I conclude by recalling that
yesterday we marked exactly one year
since the icj ordered the Russian
Federation to immediately suspend its
military operations in Ukraine
consequently we absolutely insist that
the Court's order be respected thank you
I thank the representative
of Ecuador for their statement
I give the floor to the representative
of La France
Mr President
I wish to thank Mr Griffiths for his
briefing
the Russian aggression against Ukraine
is being waged in violation of the
fundamental principles of the United
Nations Charter and of all the treaties
protecting civilians
the United Nations General Assembly once
again condemned this aggression candidly
and overwhelmingly on the 23rd of
February last
for a year millions of Ukrainian men and
women have been victims of the abuses
committed by the Russian armed forces
and their Wagner proxies they have
killed injured thousands of civilians
tortured and raped forced millions of
people to leave their homes deported
children
deliberately targeted civilian
infrastructures including schools
hospitals and energy infrastructure
the United Nations have documented these
large-scale violations of IHL and of
Human Rights
France
notes the arrest warrants issued today
by the judges of the ICC
at the request of the office of the
prosecutor against president President
Vladimir Putin and the Russian
commissioner for children's rights Maria
the court believes that there exists
sufficient evidence
to establish their involvement in the
deportation and transfer of Ukrainian
children
Russia has thought to weaken the
resistance of the Ukrainian people in
particular at a time when the country is
entering winter or was entering winter
18 million people today require
humanitarian assistance despite that
fact the Ukrainian people continue to
show
admirable courage and determination to
support those people we organized the
conference entitled solidarity with
Ukrainian people that was held in Paris
on the 13th of December and facilitated
the mobilization of more than a billion
euros to meet these urgent needs Russia
must allow access by humanitarian actors
to civilian populations this in
accordance with IHL those responsible
for abuses must be held accountable
before Europe Ukrainian courts and
before the ICC we support all
investigations underway by these actors
Mr President the Russian aggression
against Ukraine is having significant
negative repercussions throughout the
world Russia alone is responsible for
these repercussions by tackling by
attacking rather Ukrainian agricultural
infrastructure and restricting exports
by sea Russia is seeking to
instrumentalize the vulnerabilities of
certain third countries to fluctuations
in grain prices or Supply to stop food
security and Global malnutrition from
further worsening
as a result of Ukraine Russia's
aggression against Ukraine the U.N
Secretary General last July facilitated
the conclusion of the Black Sea Green
initiative It produced the expected
effects the general the Secretary
General rather recalled this fact last
Monday the FAO food price index had
reached record levels in March 2022 but
as a result of the initiative this index
has decreased for 10 months in a row
since it's signing the Black Sea gray
initiative has facilitated the export of
more than 24 million tons of grain 55 of
those grain experts were headed to
developing countries there should must
be no blackmail used when it comes to
the extension of the initiative exports
by sea of Ukrainian grain must continue
unimpeded in order to tackle food
insecurity throughout the world here as
such we commend the involvement of the
Secretary General and the contribution
made by turkey France will continue
moreover to rally alongside its European
Partners to ensure the implementation of
solidarity Lanes these have allowed
export by via waterways and by Road of
more than 29 million tons of grain and
other food products we also welcome
Ukrainian grain donations as part of the
grain from Ukraine initiative we
contributed to that initiative Mr
President in the face of that aggression
of this aggression which is having
unacceptable consequences on civilians
humanitarian support but also military
and financial support from France to
Ukraine will continue for as long as is
necessary we will continue to make the
necessary effort side by side with
Ukraine to achieve peace that is the
rationale behind our support for the
peace plan presented by president
zelinski during the G20 Summit that plan
is a pathway towards a just and Lasting
peace in Ukraine thank you
I thank
the representative of France
for their statement
I now give the flow to the
representative of the United Arab
Emirates
thank you Mr President I'd like to join
others in thanking under Secretary
General Griffiths for his informative
briefing today we support his strong
message on the Ripple effects of this
conflict across the globe the war in
Ukraine does not exist in a vacuum food
insecurity is just one way the conflict
manifests on the global stage and it
becomes a greater threat with each
passing moment
we are meeting in this chamber the day
before the expiration of the Black Sea
grain initiative one of the few
successors amidst the tragedy of this
war
for the purposes of today's discussion I
will focus on the immediate humanitarian
needs worldwide that Martin Griffiths
has just outlined let's remember why the
initiative is so important the good it
has done and why we support its full
renewal looking back at the outset of
the conflict last year a spike in food
prices threatened to send tens of
millions into extreme poverty around the
world within a week prices of wheat
Futures had jumped almost 60 percent as
the global humanitarian system struggles
to respond to the overwhelming need
around the world it is forced to contend
with the further strain of these price
Rises
all of this taking place against the
backdrop of an already stressed
post-pandemic global economy but there
is cause for some hope the impact on
global markets has been cushioned by the
Black Sea grain initiative the UN
estimates that the reduction of prices
for staple foods as a result of the bsgi
has indirectly prevented some 100
million people from falling into extreme
poverty
24 million tons of grain and over 1 600
secure vessel voyages have made it
through the Black Sea thanks to the
agreement and 55 of these food exports
are going to develop in countries
these movements represent more than
simply the grain being shipped injecting
more food into the global market brings
down food prices and so even though
exports may not be going only to the
poorest countries they are benefiting
global market prices positively for all
and they need to be preserved as such we
strongly support the secretary generals
and turkey's continued engagement with
Russia and Ukraine to ensure its full
renewal and address any issues that
impede its implementation we also note
that relevant International humanitarian
law obligations regarding civilian
vessels remain in force even if the bsgi
lapses
the UAE urges the full implementation of
the mou on Russian fertilizers and food
products also we encourage good faith
efforts to address any ongoing issues
related to Insurance Financial and
logistical infrastructure and we stand
ready to support this in any way
yet even if implemented in full the
contagion effect of War will continue to
affect agriculture blackouts across
Ukraine Financial constraints for
Ukraine's farmers and once fertile land
that now sits fallow all contribute to a
new more difficult reality for food
production in 2021 Ukraine saw record
levels of grain harvested within just
one year that was estimated to drop more
than 40 percent and areas available to
grow corn have fallen by 30 since the
outset of warm
energy is another area that has been
thrown into turmoil as a result of the
Ripple effects of this conflict the UAE
remains committed to working with the
International Community on this and to
be a responsible partner
Mr President even though the negative
impacts of the war extend far beyond
this conflict they cannot compare it to
the Dismal humanitarian situation on the
ground the impact on children in Ukraine
alone is horrifying
every day this conflict goes on more
children are exposed to the risk of
injury and death we underline the
absolute importance of the protection of
children in armed conflict as an
irrefutable obligation
the UAE is now working on the delivery
of 100 million dollars assistance
package to Ukraine to ease the suffering
on the ground but as we've said before
in this chamber another year of this
conflict will mean another year of lives
lost of communities destroyed and of
global division now firmly in its second
year the war is no longer a tragedy of a
time and place but risks becoming a
protracted immutable conflict with no
end in sight
the continued pursuit of a complete
military Victory is a barrier to
securing a just and Lasting peace we
welcome efforts by China amongst others
to try to bring the two sides together
for mediated talks this Council must
work to find solutions to the ongoing
conflict and we all need to maintain our
focus on resolving other conflicts in
countries and regions that also remain
in dire need and work together as a
council on those contexts as well in the
coming period Mr President the ravages
of War giving rise to a humanitarian
crisis both within and Beyond Ukraine's
borders and so we share a universal
clear and Urgent interest in bringing
this war to a peaceful just and enduring
end thank you Mr President
I think the representative
of the United Arab Emirates for their
statement
I now give the flow
to the representative of Switzerland
president
allow me first and foremost
to return to the vote which followed up
to the request for the participation of
a briefer at the beginning of this
meeting my country wishes to underscore
the fact that we in principles support
the council's possibility to invite
reefers that it believes qualified under
rule 39 of the council's provisional
rule of procedure we believe that such
Believers might provide an important
perspective when it comes to issues
within the council's remit today these
today Switzerland voted against the
proposal to invite the proposed briefer
because we believe that it is imperative
to consider General Assembly resolution
es11-4 for this decision by way of this
resolution all states are called upon to
refrain from any action or contact that
could be interpreted as recognition of a
change of status of the Ukrainian region
declared annexed by Russia
Mr President I wish to thank under
Secretary General Martin Griffiths for
his briefing and I underline
Switzerland's appreciation for his
efforts in particular those designed to
extend the Black Sea grain initiative as
said many many times in this room
civilian persons and objects are not a
Target International humanitarian law
and human rights must be respected and
yet the humanitarian situation in
Ukraine continues to worsen Switzerland
is concerned by the report and
conclusions published by the
international
independent Commission of inquiry on
Ukraine this week
we reiterate our support for the Mandate
of and the continuation of the work of
this commission we call upon Russia to
immediately begin de-escalation to seize
all combat operations and to withdraw
without delay its troops from the
Ukrainian territory in its entirety the
humanitarian consequences of this war
are being felt around the world
food and energy insecurity has increased
this is particularly difficult on people
who are suffering the consequences of
armed conflict or living in extreme
poverty Mr President
I would like to focus on three points
first Switzerland condemns the
persistent airstrikes targeting civilian
infrastructure these include Russia's in
indiscriminate attacks on Ukraine's
energy infrastructure Switzerland
reiterates its appeal International
humanitarian law must be fully respected
nothing it can justify targeted attacks
against civilian persons and objects
second Switzerland insists that
humanitarian workers be given unhindered
access to the almost 18 million people
in need in Ukraine including those in
areas occupied by Russia third we
reiterate the fact that the Black Sea
grain initiative along with its parallel
memorandum of understanding focused on
the export of Russian food and
fertilizers is critical to Global Food
security facilitated by the Secretary
General and turkey the initiative has
allowed the export of 24 million tons of
grain and of more than and more than 1
600 secure ship voyages across the Black
Sea the fruit price index of the FAO has
been declining for the past 10 months
having reached record levels in March
2022 this initiative must continue we
call upon all party parties to readable
their efforts to find a lasting solution
in order to alleviate the consequences
of the war we note the importance of a
long-term perspective that allows for
greater predictability
this is essential for the planning and
implementation of the initiative
Switzerland welcomes the good offices of
the Secretary General in this regard and
stands ready to provide its support
particularly in its role as host State
Mr President the International Community
continues to send out clear signals in
favor of solidarity and against
divisions in favor of dialogue and
against violence in favor of peace and
against War we are all called upon to
contribute to a comprehensive just and
Lasting peace in accordance with
international law until the Ukrainian
people can enjoy such a piece we will
emphasize as often as is necessary the
following civilian people and objects
are not a Target thank you I think the
representative
of Switzerland for their statement
I
gave the flow to the representative
of Japan
thank you Mr President I thank you SJ Mr
Griffis for his informative briefing
regrettably Russia's aggression against
Ukraine in a clear violation of
international law persists despite
widespread cause to hold it on its one
year anniversary last month
Russia's unlawful aggression has
worsened the humanitarian situation in
Ukraine and the world at the large which
is deplorable
Mr President
the humanitarian crisis has worsened in
2023 with 222 million people in 53
countries unsure if they will have
access to food
about 1 million individuals in
developing countries face extreme hunger
Russia's aggression against Ukraine has
damaged the global food supply and
worsened the humanitarian situation
in these times of precarious Global Food
Supplies the role of the Black Sea grain
initiative has become more critical than
ever before
the initiative has enabled the
exploitation of 24 million metric tons
of grain from Ukraine port and over 1
600 secure vessels voyages through the
Black Sea with 55 percent of food
exports going to developing develop
developing countries
the initiatives has been indispensable
in decreasing the worldwide cost of food
and provided
vital assistance to those who have been
significantly affected by this war
particularly in developing countries
Japan commenced the Secretary General
and his team including Mr Griffiths
Relentless efforts along with Miss
Greenspan's efforts to safeguard the
continuity and the Integrity of this
initiative by engaging with the parties
including the visit to Ukraine and the
meeting with the Russian Deputy foreign
minister
Japan strongly supports and
automatically automatic extension of the
Black Sea grain Initiative for the same
period and its further expansion and
urges involved parties to collaborate in
this regard
Mr President
Russia's aggression has severely harmed
Ukraine's agricultural sector accounting
for 10 percent of its GDP and 25 percent
of exports it is vital to restore
Ukraine's agriculture product capacity
not only for economic stability but also
to boost Global food supply
last week Japan gave sunflower and corn
seeds to 400 smallholder farmers in
harku
prioritizing win women and young Farmers
where agricultural production and farm
income have decreased due to the war
in addition to the already committed 200
million US dollar to improve Global Food
security after Russia's aggression last
June Japan decided to provide 50 million
US dollar in food related Aid to
countries in need in Asia the Middle
East Africa and Ukraine
the suffering in Ukraine and the
ramification for Global Food security
must come to the end and Japan reaffirms
its unwavering commitment to providing
the utmost support and standing in
solidarity with the people of Ukraine
Japan on its part will continue to
actively pursue effort to secure Global
food supply thereby contributing to the
maintenance of International Peace and
security I thank you Mr President
I thank
the representative
of Japan for their
statement
I now give the floor
to the representative of Albania
thank you Mr President
let me thank yousg Griffiths for his
update and
for hysterous efforts
after 13 months of continued marry me or
I'll kill you approach of Russia and
Ukraine there is little doubt that this
war is a turning point in modern history
it continues to challenge European
security
it has brought back nuclear subarattling
has disrupted the global economy leaving
energy and food crisis in its wake
but it has also been Awakening Awakening
moment reminding everyone that for as
long as there will be
authoritarians around peace should never
be taken for granted
while the reality on the ground has
revealed the limits of this modern
Madness persistent waves of deadly
missiles strikes across Ukraine
the Russian death signature continued to
destroy civilian infrastructure with no
end in sight
they constitute crimes
for months we have heard here
Russia doesn't attack civilians but the
reality the hard and painful reality is
completely different more than twenty
thousand civilians have been killed or
wounded 14 million people have been
uprooted from their homes 18 million
people require humanitarian assistance
and protection and around 40 percent of
ukrainians are unable to afford or
excess enough food
for months we have heard here Russia
doesn't commit crimes
the hard reality which we know and have
denounced here is now confirmed by the
report of the commission of inquiry and
independent and impersonal expert body
Russian authorities have committed a
wide range of violations of
international human rights law and
national material law in various regions
of Ukraine many of which amount to war
crimes
everything in the horrible book of
crimes is there
attacks on civilian and energy related
infrastructure willful killings unlawful
confinement torture rape and other
sexual violence as well as unlawful
transfer of and deportation of children
these facts show the depth of depravity
of the aggression total disregard for
civilians and the sanctity of human
lives
colleagues
Ukraine war for this one fundamental
question for all of us
what kind of world we want to live in
the current rules based or World Order
is the one that emerged From the Ashes
of World War II one where powerful
autocratic regimes would no longer be
free to Devour the neighbors one where
more democracies than ever have been
able to flourish and where free markets
and open trade have lifted more people
out of poverty than any time in the
history of the world
it is clear that it is this order that
made almost 80 years without a war of
aggression the kind of War just like
what is happening in Ukraine that can
destabilize the whole world
it is this order which is based on
international law and rules not imposed
by anyone but agreed by three nations
it is an order which has made it that
when there is transgression there are
consequences just like the arrest
warrants issued today by the ICC
the man who started this war of choice
the man who is responsible for its
continuation and all the terrible
consequences is now a man wanted by
International Justice
this is the first victory of
accountability it is a first wake-up
call for everyone who is fighting an
unjust and illegal war in Ukraine that
impunity that has emboldened
perpetrators during these long months of
War has lasted far too long
Mr President what happens in Ukraine
today will concern all of us tomorrow
this is why support Ukraine goes beyond
mere solidarity for people in need it is
an urgent call for World in peril
the grain initiative a Lifeline for
dozens of countries around the world
should be extended not with fixed
deadlines but in defense
indefinitely because as u.sg Graphics
clearly explained so are the needs of
hundreds of millions of people whose
daily food depends of it
Mr President every day into the war is
making the world a more and more
dangerous place without any reason and
out of choice
it is therefore never late for Russia to
come to reality seize all hostilities
and unconditionally completely and
immediately will draw all its forces and
military equipment from the entire
territory of Ukraine within its
International organized borders
Russia can earn back its respect not by
committing more crimes but by resulting
to peace until then we will continue to
stand with Ukraine and its people in
their just struggle to repeal aggression
and restore their territory Independence
and sovereignty I thank you
I thank the representative
of Albania for their statement
I now give
the flow to the Russian Federation
Mr President
even that our former Western partners
have been shameful and have not allowed
an opportunity for the refer from
donbass to speak we will now have to
listen to their statement today
and it will be lengthier than usual
Mr President our discussion at the
security Council of humanitarian aspects
of the Ukrainian crisis is consistently
carried out based on the same template
Western countries have been highlighting
the destruction of Civilian
infrastructure in Ukraine and
disregarding the fact that if the key of
regime had been complying with the Norms
of IHL specifically the non-placement of
heavy weaponry and anti-aircraft systems
in residential areas then that civilians
would not be in the crossfire because
our army carries out exclusively High
Precision strikes targeting energy and
transport infrastructure objects we are
doing this to degrade the military
potential and capacity of Ukraine which
the collective West is doing everything
possible to shore up with the deliveries
of new weapons
we have been carrying out a number of
meetings to demonstrate the Staggering
profits received from the weapons
deliveries by Western weapons producing
corporations of course they have no
interest in an end to the hostilities
and their interests are obsequiously
being Advanced by politicians just
yesterday the representative of the
White House John Kirby in response to a
question about the Chinese peace plan in
Ukraine stated that the end to
hostilities in Ukraine I quote will
constitute a violation of the United
Nations Charter end of quote and earlier
in the beginning of March the secretary
of the Ukrainian National Security
Council danielov regarded the fact that
in his country there are more and more
people who are advocating and peace
talks with the Russian Federation in
other words the Kiev regime regrets the
fact that Ukrainian citizens want peace
with our country and this speaks for
itself
it is important that the real goals of
Kia for the real goals of Kiev and its
Western Partners to be understood by
developing countries during the attempts
that will once again be undertaken to
attempt to mobilize their support in
support of new anti-russian initiatives
at the general assembly at the same time
Western countries are setting aside the
method the methodical and targeted
shelling by the Ukrainian forces of the
civilian facilities objects in dunbas
which have been ongoing for nine years
now
so we believe it is our objective now to
provide a full picture and to focus
specifically on what our Western
colleagues have failed to mention
today's brief rodaria amaroseable whose
statement Western colleagues were so
afraid of
plan to provide a retrospective of the
devastating internal Ukrainian conflict
and the subsequent humanitarian crisis
which was provoked which provoked by the
anti-constitutional coup in Kiev in
February of 2014 she as a native so this
was possible however some some of the uh
subjects and premises from her statement
is something which she requested that we
share with you large-skill peace
peaceful protests and major
russian-speaking regions were a natural
response to interconstitutional action
of the new authorities people took to
the streets in the hopes of being heard
the only demand their only demand was
meeting with representatives of Kiev
instead in violation of article 17 of
the Constitution of Ukraine which
prohibits the use of armed Ukrainian
Armed Force and illegal armed groups to
limit civilian rights and freedoms the
key of regime turned its Army against
the peaceful protesters with the use of
air assets artillery and mass lethal
artillery and equipment
Mass lethal impact Weaponry it's
military crimes is something which the
key of regime Justified with the conduct
of the so-called anti-terrorism
operation the decree for which was
signed on 14 April 2014 by an individual
who illegitimately was vested with
constitutional presidential Authority at
the same time not a DPR Nord LPR
throughout the entire conflict in
southeast Ukraine were recognized
officially as terrorist organizations
and consequently they could not fall
under International criteria defining
that back in 2014 and based on the
conclusion of the icrc the conflict in
Ukraine was recognized as being domestic
namely a civil war
and in addition to open hostilities Kiev
began to harshly quell peaceful protests
through socioeconomic restrictions the
region was subjected to an economic
blockade payments were ended of all
social benefits including pensions and
banking services were and for
individuals and businesses were stopped
food blockade the medicine
food and basic necessities were all
blocked it was a transport blockade an
information blockade real information
about events in dunbas was on mass
supplanted with nationalist propaganda
furthermore Ukraine ended the work of
all government bodies agencies and
organizations on the territory of the
region in this way local residents were
deprived of the opportunity to receive
basic government services social
assistance and perhaps such key
documents as passports birth
certificates death certificates so
opportunities for any documents to be
provided that attest to civil status in
December of 2014 and March of 2017
socioeconomic restrictions against the
region were enshrined at the legislative
level in this way Kiev legalized
decisions against their own citizens
these steps have resulted in irrevocable
consequences from the beginning of the
conflict in the beginning and as of 24
February 2022 as a result of the Armed
aggression by Ukraine on the territory
of DPR
4374 people died including 91 children
nearly 8 000 civilians were wounded to
varying degrees
uh and this includes two 323 children no
fewer than 27 of them were left with
disabilities as a result of the fire of
the Ukrainian armed groups from the
beginning of the Special Operation
there's that resulted in destruction of
more than of approximately 23 000
residential buildings including five
thousand uh buildings and these were
raised to the ground there were
approximately 850 educational facilities
that were destroyed 350 Health Care
Facilities were destroyed 800 utility
facilities were destroyed and they had
been providing gas water fuel and
electricity to the residents of the
Republic from 2017 to in 2017 and 17
February 2022 alone on that day alone
there were more than 339 000 Munitions
that were launched the varying calibers
the International Community did not
provide an objective response a nor
relevant actions uh vis-a-vis the
actions undertaken to sabotage the men's
process in the time a key
Representatives did not comply with a
single package in the midst package of
agreements on the implementation of the
agreement both officially representative
as an official representative DPR of the
men's group and humanitarian
issueseva assures us that representative
is a key if we're not geared towards or
focused on implementation of any
agreements whatsoever moreover they
sabotaged any progress that could have
ended this Bloodshed and I would add in
my own capacity and this is something
which westerns their Western sponsors
encouraged
against the backdrop of a lack of peace
goals and the process there was a
heightened tension on the line of
contact there were clear provocations
from Kiev in the week alone that
preceded
the announcement of mass evacuations in
dunbas in breach of the ceasefire
agreement Ukrainian armed groups
launched against the territory of DPR
nearly 100 Munitions which have been
prohibited under the Minsk agreements
furthermore Ukrainian soldiers received
a direct instruction from the commander
of the Ukrainian forces the illusion of
to open fire without agreement on their
own discretion there were registered
facts of drones being used with IEDs to
Target strikes against civilians and the
eve of the events Ukraine began to step
up and strengthen its positions on the
front not only through its soldiers but
also using weapons of mass destruction
Kiev Was preparing for a full-fledged
military operation in dunbas which was
planned for early March 2022 this became
clear after the
significant uptick and the escalation of
the military aggression of Ukrainian
Armed Forces since the beginning of the
military operation to liberate the area
of the regions of Don bosmorph and more
facts have been uncovered at Large Scale
war crimes by the Ukrainian authorities
their numbers are increasing as the
progress is made towards the front line
there have been has been a tremendous
amount of testimony from civilians
showing that Ukrainian armed forces have
prevented civilians from evacuating the
area of hostilities people have been
used as human shields for example in the
cities of mariopolabahov and salidar
when the Ukrainian Army retreated there
was a deliberate destruction
of what survived during hostilities I
referred to civilian infrastructure and
homes in the year of the military
special military operation and the
territory of DPR alone along the border
from the beginning of Special Operation
there are more than 15 500 instances of
the Ukrainian Armed Forces carry out a
shelling and more than 15 000 of these
included the use of heavy artillery the
adversary the foe launched against the
Republic more than one hundred thousand
Munitions of various calibers including
39.
um
ammunitions more than 220 uh High Mars
missiles more than 250 order got bm-27
Oregon
systems and more than 13
122 MLS systems as well as more than 21
500 155 caliber shells beginning with
June of 2022 the Ukrainian forces have
been using
anti-personnel mines Aleppo stock mines
or butterfly mines uh Lutheran using
these mines Ukraine has been remotely
mining the heavily densely populated
areas in DPR there have been more than
90 instances of of residents coming upon
these mines and having them blow up this
includes nine children one of the
victims died in a hospital and many of
those who have had to have limbs
amputated in an attempt to generate a
humanitarian disaster in the region Kiev
has been training terrorist attacks and
provocations targeting key
infrastructure in Dunbar specifically
water and energy infrastructure has been
targeted
as a result of this terrorist act these
terrorist acts has been a complete end
to the delivery of water to the Republic
from the main artery the northern Don
nietzstanbusk channel the majority of
DPR have been receiving water once every
three days for just a few hours and the
technical Waters being provided and
drinking water is being received by the
residents in the former intern
assistance there have been Mass
instances of torture and executions of
hostages in Ukraine civilians in areas
under key of control have been suggested
to political persecution repression and
ideological grounds by the intelligence
forces these actions are cynical and in
so doing Ukraine has not only violated
all existing norms and standards of
international humanitarian law but also
has been demonstrated contempt for the
most basic principles of humanity
humanism and mercy and this flow of
Neo-Nazi hatred has engulfed both the
residents of the their People's Republic
of Don Bosque as well as the citizens
who from the very beginning of the
special military operation have been
residing in territories under kiev's
regime I repeat what I stated just now
this is the text part of the text
part of the briefing that should have
been delivered by Daya marozova this is
effectively a direct statement from the
resident of dambas which people in the
west are absolutely trying to disregard
and
for the sake of saving their lives a
little over a year ago the special
military operation was launched for my
part I would note that in recent months
we have once again seen the terrorist
and inhumane nature of the key of regime
until March in briansk in the Russian
Federation members of the Ukrainian
Armed Forces perpetrated a terrorist
attack during which they attacked a
vehicle transporting three children to
school they killed the driver they
wounded an 11 year old boy he
nonetheless was able to extricate
himself from the vehicle he helped to
first grade girls
leave the vehicle as well and the three
children then fleeing the terrorists
sought to find shelter in a neighboring
hedge the wounder wounded boy
demonstrated himself to be without a
doubt a real man this cannot be said
about the Ukrainian fighters who have
been firing at the backs of children who
were fleeing into the forest attempting
to and then this was an attempt to leave
no Witnesses of the sabotage groups and
the Ukrainian nationalist battalions are
firing at Russian speakers in the cities
of dambas attempting to pass this office
crimes perpetrated by the Russian army
and there's a great deal of such
evidence that has already been gathered
by our investigative bodies this is a
deliberate planned attack against the
residents of
of villages which has have no military
facilities in other words this is a real
terrorist attack the perpetrators of
this participants of some kind of a
mythical Russian voluntary core are
units of the Ukrainian Armed Forces
Foreign Legion operating following the
orders of the Ukrainian military
leadership the zelansky regime has been
attempting to distance himself from the
sabotage because these crimes are so
abhorrent however the leader of the
sabotage group announced that this
action was agreed upon with Ikea regime
carried out with its direct assistance
incidentally this character is a
well-known including in Europe Neo-Nazi
and racist who has been prohibited from
entering the European Union it is hardly
surprising that as with others with
these kinds of views he felt himself to
be completely comfortable in Ukraine and
with impunity perpetrated his crimes
with the approval of the key of
leadership it is not really clear what
through such Cold Blood murder of
children the key of regime is attempting
to achieve to increase support from the
West if the West was willing to support
this regime carrying out such egregious
acts then this is the same crime that
the West would not be able to hide with
his maniacal and vain desire to secure
the defeat of the Russian Federation in
the battlefield we on the whole have
heard a great deal of testimony about
how western states are directly involved
in the conflict not just through
provision of weapons to Ukraine but also
by directly participating in the direct
participation of the military specialist
for example there was revealing evidence
that was provided to the Russian law
enforcement bodies by a former American
Soldier enlisted in the so-called
Ukrainian Foreign Legion and the
Nationals Battalion the Carpathian whip
John McIntyre documents maps and other
information were provided by him and
they confirm the direct coordination of
the actions of the Ukrainian forces and
the battlefield with U.S military and
intelligence agencies this evidence will
underpin the legal assessment of the
level of Engagement and participation of
foreign officials in the crimes
perpetrated by the Kia regime against
civilians
Mr McIntyre also described the abhorrent
crimes and torture perpetrated against
prisoners of War at the hands of
Ukrainian groups these and other this
and other evidence of our uh something
which our opponents imagining some kind
of Russian crimes will simply disregard
however Ukrainian and Western sadists
and criminals would not be left without
punishment in Russia there's already an
intern uh an international communal
tribunal that is in operation it could
is collecting witness testimony and
documenting this and the their
preparations to establish and launch a
an international tribunal that is rooted
in international law and not a
rules-based order which the collective
West says devised to advance their own
interests and for the following example
of the shots fired at Russian children
and Beyond obless we can understand how
the regime treats children given the
Reckless and aggressive policies and the
inhumane policies of the Ukrainian
authorities the head of DPR and LPR in
the beginning of the Special Operation
February 2022 adopted a decision to
evacuate civilians including children to
the Russian Federation
as of 27 February 2023 from the
beginning of the Special Operation the
Russian Federation was the destination
for approximately four thousand four
point five million uh evacuees from
approxima Inca including approximately
000 children their overwhelming majority
of the evacuated children who reached
Russia were accompanied by their parents
custodians and Guardians in this
connection we just dismayed by the
speculation about the alleged not large
numbers of unaccompanied children in the
Russian Federation Russia during as part
of our bilateral cooperation with ohchr
with UNICEF and with the icrc has been
providing credible information about
measures undertaken by our country to
prevent the violation of IHL against
children in order to prevent speculation
about this which has become a beloved
subject of propagandists in Kiev in the
West in early April we will organize and
informal Security Council Ariel formula
meeting on this issue Mr President many
here today touched upon the subject of
the Black Sea grain initiative and if we
are to talk about it more accurately the
package deal the extension of which for
60 days in a 60-day extension of which
could be carried out tomorrow and to
conclude I wish I wish to conclude with
detailed information about our position
in this regard
on 20 to July last year in Turkey two
package namely interlinked agreements
were signed the first at the point at
that point was designed to address the
humanitarian objective of providing food
to starving people throughout the world
this was signed by Russia turkey and
Ukraine to export food and fertilizer
through three black sea ports the second
package was signed between the Russian
Federation the U.N Secretariat to help
to facilitate to the Russian food
products and grain reaching the global
markets and this specifically is what
our colleagues our Western colleagues
obstinately wish not to notice avoiding
even any mention of this in the council
products there is not an iota of a
mention of this being made turning to
the implementation of the so-called
grain initiative the purpose of which is
to facilitate the export of grain from
Ukrainian ports we like many others have
many questions the main question is as
follows why did it suddenly transform
from a humanitarian initiative to a
commercial one and this is specifically
what statistics show also highly
contentious is its impact on global food
prices the poorest countries
and I received not 66 or 65 percent of
the products contrary to what was said
here today in this chamber but merely
approximately three percent
specifically according to the data from
yongtad despite the fact that food
prices have fallen from record highs in
early last year to 2020 later only 20 no
more than 20 percent of 21 2021 levels
domestic problems are also worsening
developing countries and this is a
consequence of local currency
devaluation and this is against the
backdrop of the US dollar gaining
strength in 2022 who do you think is
benefiting from this situation the main
beneficiaries of growing food prices and
the stabilization of Supply chains are
the leading Western Agro corporations
I am talking about the so-called big
four the American Archer Daniels Midland
bunge and cargo as well as the Dutch
Louis Dreyfus which account for 75 to 90
percent of global trade for the
agro-industrial complex in 2022 Cargill
alone increased sale volumes by 23 to
165 billion dollars reaching record net
profits of 5 billion dollars what
bonuses will developing countries what
are the bonuses for developing countries
here
parenthetically let's not forget about
the fact that as a result of the
unbridled of the uncontrolled food
exports from Ukraine in this country is
liable to itself encounter significant
hunger which many experts talk about
this and the Russian experts have also
talked about this and this includes the
question of Western companies seizure of
Black Sea croplands in that country or
the past 10 years the number of these
the amount of these lands that fell into
the hands of foreign control surpassed 4
million hectares or 10 percent of all
fertile lands moreover their attempts to
conceal in these processes uh the these
processes are part of an attempt to
advance a traditional Mantra of Russian
aggression and accusations against our
country of creating a food process and
provoking growing food prices is of
course complete lies
even in the European Parliament
resolution access on accessibility of
fertilizer in the U.S dating 16 February
explicitly says that high prices in the
Agro sector have been observed over the
past two years and moreover this has not
prevented Brussels from provoking and
generating additional risks in food
security for poor countries through new
anti-russian restrictions Mr President
the memorandum is simply not working it
is it being beneficial for developing
countries is something nobody truly
cares about ultimately the U.N Through
official Representatives that
Secretariat had to recognize that the
organization has no leverage to exempt
Russian agricultural export operations
from Western sanctions once again I
stress this is a situation that has
adversely been affecting not Russia our
economy to the dismay of our Western
adversaries is steadily developing but
is affecting adversely the developing
world but all of this concern about them
the state of concerns which from Western
colleagues is mere words the efforts of
the Secretary General have not generated
results and we cannot accept that either
and in this connection 13 march pursuant
to paragraph h of the Twilight agreement
we officially informed through a note
that Turkish and Ukrainian side that we
didn't object to extending following 18
March its operations for a period of 16
days that is until 18 May further steps
will depend on progress in addressing
the issues which we have highlighted to
conclude if Brussels Washington and
London are genuinely interested to
continue the export of food from Ukraine
through the maritime humanitarian
Corridor and this is then they have two
months to exempt from their sanctions
the entire chain of operations which
accompany the Russian Agro agricultural
sector otherwise so we fail to
understand how the package concept of
the Secretary General of the United
Nations will work through the Istanbul
agreements to conclude Mr President
I turn to the order handed down by the
ICC that was mentioned here today the
warrant this is a Prejudice political
biased non-competent in an international
body which has once again demonstrated
how damaging and invalided it is the ICC
is a puppet in the hands of the
collective West which is always willing
to carry it out to pseudo legal
pseudo-jurisdiction based on their
orders what is particularly cynical is
that legally invalid rulings were
disclosed on the eve of the anniversary
of the U.S Invasion into Iraq where the
ICC had jurisdiction but did absolutely
nothing to bring the perpetrators to
account the Russian Federation is not
party to the Rome statute the ICC lacks
jurisdiction vis-a-vis the Russian
Federation its citizens consider we
consider anybody any warrants from these
and from this body as illegitimate it
and invalid and null and void on all
indicators the ICC has really taken the
path towards self-liquidation first and
foremost with respect to its Authority
and international recognition and we
this is an obvious judgment and I will
provide a quote of the U.S advisor on
National Security John Bolton dating
2018.
he said we will allow the ICC to be
independent ultimately
in every respect it is not there thank
you
I thank the representative
of the Russian Federation
for their statement
I now give the fall to the
representative of Brazil
thank you Mr President
Mr President I think West G grift is for
his contribution
we have been following with extreme
concern the attacks in recent weeks
against Targets in various cities in
Ukraine as well as the dramatic fighting
around Bahamut
Brazil reiterates the call for all
parties to fully respect International
humanitarian law and international human
rights law
it's a universal responsibility to
ensure the protection and safety of
civilians provide a humanitarian Aid to
those in need and treats that they needs
humanely
there are no negotiations these are
non-negotiable obligations
Brazil is also deeply concerned with the
lack of improvement in the humanitarian
situation in Ukraine
urban areas continues to be shelled and
civilian infrastructure destroyed
we remind both parties of these councils
of these council's resolutions
2417 is last 2018 which indicates Our
obligation to respect civilian objects
and critical infrastructure for
delivering humanitarian Aid and to
ensure the proper functioning of food
systems and markets
in order to put an end to this
humanitarian crisis it's necessary to
seek pragmatic Solutions
we urge all memory states to pursue
realistic ways to achieve peace
protecting human life and safeguarding
human dignity must always come first
in this regard we would like to mention
three points
first it's necessary to keep the
channels open for dialogue
insisting on Military Solutions
reinforced by unilateral sanctions will
not lead to an end to this conflict
dialogue is the way to de-escalate and
build trust
when there is a when there is engagement
it is possible to achieve positive
results as demonstrated by the Black Sea
brain initiative
second
it is urgent that the two sides agree to
cease hostilities in accordance with
resolution es 11 stroke 6 adopted by the
general assembly in February
continuing
to fight will deepen the humanitarian
crisis increased casualties and Destroy
infrastructures without resolving the
underlying causes of the conflict
the continuation of this war also
affects other countries in the immediate
neighborhood as well as in developing
nations hard hit by the collateral
effects of the conflict on their
economies and with limited resources and
instruments to counter these effects
third
and last Point Mr President we reiterate
our support for a negotiated solution
that takes into account ways to prevent
renewed violence in the future
Brazil considers
it is essential to understand the
security concerns of the parties
involved and respond to them in a
constructive and pragmatic manner
we are ready to engage along with other
leading countries in diplomatic efforts
based on the principles of the UN
Charter and with the goal of a just and
sustainable peace in the long term and I
thank you
I think
the representative of Brazil for their
statement
I now give the floor the representative
of China
Mr President
I thank USG greenfields for his briefing
the Ukraine crisis
has a direct on
to today's situation and it's getting
increasingly expanded and complex the
humanitarian situation continued to
deteriorate the prospect for peace
remains elusive China is deeply worried
about all of these conflicts and wall
benefit no one bloody confrontations
only increase worrying only increased
suffering we call all relevant parties
to truly put the people at the center
Step Up actions and do their utmost to
mitigate the humanitarian consequences
of the conflict while at the same time
stepping up efforts to de-escalate the
situation and receive hostilities as
quickly as possible in this connection I
wish to make the following points first
the basic Norms of international
humanitarian law must be earnestly
observed under any circumstances the
protection of civilians must come first
parties to the conflict must avoid
attacking civilians and civilian
facilities
ensure the normal functioning of the key
public services such as energy
Healthcare and education protect the
victims of the conflict and respect the
basic rights of prisoners of War all
parties to the conflict should stay
rational and exercise maximum restraint
and avoid actions that endanger the
safety insecurity of nuclear facilities
to minimize the risk of accidents China
supports iaea in fulfilling its
safeguards functions and the playing an
active role in promoting the Safety and
Security of nuclear facilities
China will contribute
two hundred thousand Euros through iaea
to technical assistance to Ukraine our
nuclear Safety and Security second every
effort must be made to maintain the
scope and the intensity of humanitarian
relief since the outbreak of the
conflict the affected areas have seen a
severe material deprivation and a
serious shortage of water electricity
and the heat supplies China has provided
multiple batches of emergency
humanitarian Aid to Ukraine and
developing countries affected by the
spillovers of the crisis the
International Community should scale up
relief for all affected people speed up
the repair and restoration of Civilian
infrastructures and do its utmost to
mitigate the impact of the conflicts on
people's lives relevant parties should
ensure Rapid Safe and unimputed
humanitarian access and support UN in
playing its coordinating role in
humanitarian Affairs women children and
displaced persons are vulnerable groups
in armed conflicts targeted assistance
should be provided to meet their special
needs third the spillovers of the
conflict must be managed all parties
should work together in a responsible
manner to mitigate the impact of the
crisis on International Energy Finance
food trade and transportation to
maintain the momentum of global economic
recovery relevant countries should stop
abusing unilateral sanctions and
long-term long-arm jurisdiction to
eliminate the disruption of
international economic trade cooperation
caused by those measures China commands
a Secretary General Contreras for his
active communication with all parties on
the extension of the Black Sea Green
initiative we hope that the initiative
will be implemented fully and
effectively in a balanced manner at the
same time China hopes that the United
Nations will actively
implement the mou signed with Russia
Force diplomatic efforts for peaceful
solution must be relentlessly Advanced
no matter how complex the situation is
at the door to a political settlement
cannot be closed and efforts for peace
cannot be slackened the International
Community must promote talks for peace
with utmost urgency create conditions
for the resumption of negotiations and
promote the party's concern to do so
without preconditions at an early date
to give peace a chance facts have shown
that continuous supply of offensive
weapons and Resort into group
confrontation and the political
isolation do not help to resolve the
crisis on the Ukraine issue China always
stands on the side of Peace dialogue and
Humanity China has issued its position
on the political settlement of the
Ukraine crisis and will continue to work
with the International Community to play
an active role in the political
settlement of the crisis
before I conclude
I wish to State our principled position
on the procedural vote conducted before
the start of the meeting
China regrets that the council had to
have
a procedural vote on whether Miss davia
marzova should be invited to brief the
council at his China's position that the
council should make a decision on the
issue by consensus through patient
consultation
we believe that the Castle's decision on
this issue should both comply with its
provisional rules of procedure and be
consistent with the past practice of
dividing briefers
so as to avoid
leaving the impression of applying
double standards I also wish to
reiterate that China's position on the
Ukraine issue remains unchanged
thank you Mr President
I thank the representative
of China for their statement
I give the floor to
the representative of Ghana
Mr President
at the outset let me explain
that Ghana voted in favor of the
proposal to admit Miss diarrhea
morozova under rule 39 of the Kansas
rules council's provisional rules of
procedure provide the council with her
personal views regarding this
humanitarian situation in the dormas
region of Ukraine
as we have consistently done
we have supported the President's Choice
of briefest and this in no way impairs
our position on the danbos region being
a part of Ukraine
indeed it affirms Ukraine's sovereignty
to be clear Ghana does not recognize the
so-called the next People's Republic
including any person purporting to act
in any official capacity on behalf of
that entity
Miss murozova as we understand it it's a
residence of the dombas region and by
extension a citizen of Ukraine
in that sense we are of the view that
her personal views as a citizen of
Ukraine should be admitted by the
council
Mr President turning to the subject of
our meeting I would like to thank USG
Griffiths for the important updates
provided to the Council on the
prevailing humanitarian conditions in
Ukraine
we continue to Value his contributions
to resolving this aspect of the war
bordering on the survival of the people
of Ukraine
Ghana continues to be deeply concerned
about the overall humanitarian situation
and in particular the plight of innocent
civilians caught in the crossfires of
intense combat raging across several
cities in Ukraine
if the contestation in back mode Odessa
the next and other front lines share
anything in common
it is the fact that we see Rising
casualties and further destruction
they have impaled energy infrastructure
of Ukraine they already impaled energy
infrastructure of Ukraine continues to
be pummeled with no regard for the needs
of the civilians who rely on Need for
their Survivor especially during this
winter season
while the destroyed infrastructure can
can be rebuilt the destruction in the
minds and hearts of the people
hidden from our eyes is perhaps worse
than we have imagined they may never be
restored from the deep loss and Trauma
of this brutal War
it is for this reason that we remain
supportive of initiatives to provide
mental health care and counseling and
counseling support for ukrainians
affected by the war especially children
UNICEF reports that despite the growing
impact of the war on the 7.5 million
children in Ukraine
they continue to show tremendous
resilience for survival
we must do all that lies in our power to
bring an end to the scourge of the war
on their lives
Mr President the report of the
independent International Commission of
inquiry on Ukraine issued on 15th March
2023 regrettably Bears out our fears of
widespread and systematic human rights
violations this regard for civilians and
possible war crimes
we note the report as an important
contribution to International efforts
aim at ensuring accountability for the
horrendous crimes being committed in
Ukraine
we further agree with the commission
that there is no there is the need for
further investigations and comprehensive
accountability including criminal
responsibility of the perpetrators and
the rights of victims to truth
reparations and non-repetition
at the core of the prohibition of the
use of force as a means for the
settlement of dispute is the value for
human life and the essential obligation
to protect and preserve Humanity from
the harms of War
International humanitarian law is
therefore intended to impose on Warren
parties obligations for the protection
of civilians and even the treatment of
prisoners of War during such times we
deeply regret that these fundamental
principles have not been obliged and
more people continue to suffer
needlessly with each passing day of the
war
in view of the western humanitarian
conditions we renew our appeal to the
parties to ensure compliance with their
obligations under international law
International humanitarian law and human
rights law
civilians must be protected from harm
and prisoners of war must be treated
with respect in accordance with the
measures prescribed under the Geneva
conventions and additional protocols
the continuing missile attacks near the
Japanese
nuclear power plant resulting in the
temporary loss of its only remaining
backup power line
point to the growing risk of a cost of
catastrophic nuclear incident
we remind the parties of the existential
and intergenerational harm caused by
nuclear arms and urge them to rethink
their actions in the interests of
humanity
as we all stand at risks from any such
incident whether accidental or
calculated
we urge the parties to treat nuclear
Safety and Security as non-negotiable
and to undertake the steps outlined by
the iaea including immediately
demilitarization of all nuclear
facilities in Ukraine
Mr President after 13 months of
sustained violence exchanges across all
of Ukraine their peers know
there appears to be no hope
to an end in sight
and little appetite on the part of the
warring parties for a peaceful
settlement
we continue to be concerned about the
inflammatory rhetoric and the heightened
risks of a wider dual political conflict
involving other European nations
if peace in Ukraine is to be attained
the parties must relinquish any military
logic to winning the war
we remain firmly of the view the
dialogue and diplomacy offer the best
chances of a comprehensive peace process
that would address their respective
concerns of the parties and Retreat our
call for the intensification of
international effort for a comprehensive
just and Lasting peace in Ukraine
it has been well asserted in this
Council and the general assembly that
peace in Ukraine must be founded on the
purposes and principles of the United
Nations Charter and should seek to
uphold the sovereignty political
Independence and territorial Integrity
of Ukraine in accordance with
international law
Mr President we encourage agreement for
the federal renewal of the Black Sea
Green initiative when it expires on 18th
March this year as it once again offers
a glimmer of hope through the dark
of this war
we are encouraged by the commitment made
by the parties given the significant
impact the deal has shown to have on
global food supply chain and Market
stability and we urge its full
implementation in line with terms with
the terms of the agreement
we thank the Secretary General for his
visit to Kiev on 8th March where he held
discussions with president zielinski on
the continuation of the grain initiative
the good faith implementation of all
stakeholders is now crucial to sustain
its integrity
in a manner that assures its future
extension for much longer periods of
time
we also underline the importance and the
necessity of further effort and
cooperation in relation to the export of
Russian ammonia and Agro products
Mr President humanitarian assistance and
protection is vital to saving lives and
mitigating the impacts on the people
as we all know however it does not
replace the critical need for the
cessation of all hostility of all
violent hostilities
it is for this reason and in the
interest of the many suffering women
children and vulnerable persons that we
re Echo the cause made to the Russian
Federation to end the aggression against
its neighbor Ukraine
it is time to end the war
and begin the tax of charting the path
of peace between the Russian Federation
and Ukraine I thank you very much Mr
President
I think
the representative
of Ghana
or their statement I now give the fall
to the representative of Malta
thank you president I also thank USG
Griffiths for his briefing
over a year has passed since Russia
launched its aggression against Ukraine
this growth violation of the U.N
chartered international law has led to
yet another
man-made humanitarian catastrophe
today the war threatens not only Ukraine
and the region but millions of people
across the world
president as we have heard over 17
million people nearly 40 percent of the
population of Ukraine require
humanitarian assistance and protection
as a result of this war
more than 8 million Ukrainian refugees
have been recorded across Europe
5.4 million people have been internally
displaced
we have all witnessed a humanitarian
consequences of the systematic use of
missiles and drones to attack civilian
objects and infrastructure indispensable
to the survival of the civilian
population across Ukraine
not least in Tuesday's missile strike on
an apartment building in chromatosk
such attacks have left Millions without
power Heating and water for days in the
middle of winter
compounding the hardship for a most for
the most vulnerable caught up in this
fighting especially those in areas close
to the front lines and outside the
control of Ukrainian authorities
furthermore we have also seen the
horrific effects from the use of
explosive weapons with wide area effects
in populated areas with Town squares and
residential apartment blocks reduced to
rubber
Malta once again calls on the Russian
Federation to see such attacks which
constitute a violation of international
law
president the devastating impacts of
Russia's war on children women and men
will be failed for Generations we
condemn the pattern of international
humanitarian and human rights law
violations related to the use of sexual
violence as a weapon of War
Malta also deploys the unlawful transfer
and forced deportation of Ukrainian
out of Ukraine of more than six thousand
children such actions constitute war
crimes
in this regard Malta supports the
international criminal courts efforts to
ensure that all those involved in
violations of international humanitarian
and human rights law are held
accountable
in addition we welcome the important
work being carried out by the
independent International Commission on
inquiry on Ukraine and support the idea
of establishing a register of Damages as
a record of evidence and information on
claims for damages loss or injury caused
by Russia's war of aggression against
Ukraine
such initiatives will support the much
needed reconstruction of Civilian
infrastructure destroyed in Ukraine over
the past decade as a result of the
conflict
president Malta is concerned that many
of those in disparate need of
humanitarian assistance are enabled or
prevented from accessing the services
they need
we commend the work of the U.N its
partner agencies and all humanitarian
organizations working in such dangerous
situations and appeal for the full
facilitation of humanitarian access and
operations throughout the country
especially in the areas along front
lines
Malta highlights the importance of the
continuance of the Black Sea grain
initiative the this initiative has
allowed the export of tons of grains and
other foodstuffs prolonging the
agreement is crucial for the stability
of international prices and for the
continuous flow of grains helping people
worldwide struggling to put food on
their tables and support Farmers whose
incomes have plummeted because of the
war
additionally we reiterate our call for
ampedes and repeated access to be
granted to the icrc for all Ukrainian
prisoners of War military cause that
under the third Geneva Convention all
prisoners of War are entitled to receive
regular visits from icrc delegates
president as the war in Ukraine begins
to ramp up once again we reiterate our
call on the Russian Federation to
immediately seize its hostilities and to
withdraw all Russian forces from
Ukraine's internationally recognized
voters
more than enough lives have been lost
families torn apart and civilians
traumatized by a year of Carnage let us
see the escalation and dialogue in the
days and weeks ahead rather than this
continued cycle of death and destruction
thank you
I thank the representative of Malta
for they are a statement
I now give the floor
through the representative of the United
Kingdom
thank you presidents
I will say thank USG Griffiths for his
briefing today
president today over 21 million people
need humanitarian assistance as a result
of Russia's full-scale invasion
this is over 50 percent of Ukraine's
pre-war population
of these people over 5 million are
displaced internally
and another 8 million have fled to
Europe as refugees
this is the most significant
displacement seen anywhere in the world
for decades
in areas under Russian control
approximately four million people were
an acute need of humanitarian protection
and assistance
and these figures demonstrate the
devastating nature
with Russia's actions in Ukraine
we must not forget that behind every
number in these millions
is a person
a brother or a sister
a mother or a father
whose normal life has been destroyed by
Russia's aggression
president I will focus on the situation
in bakmud
the city has been subjects near constant
shelling with civilian infrastructure
such as schools water and energy and
health facilities
taking significant damage
there are not many buildings left
standing and the humanitarian
consequences of Russia's brutal assaults
are extreme
humanitarian assistance into the city
stopped in mid-February
when the fighting intensified and it
became too dangerous for most aides to
get in
nearly 4 000 civilians remain
hiding in basements
these people are severely vulnerable
in particular children persons with
disabilities and the elderly
only in limited number of local
volunteer groups have been able to
distribute assistance at Great risk to
their personal safety
we therefore called for unimpeded and
sustained humanitarian access to the
people of Ukraine including in bakmud
Russia must stop denying access and must
cease its attacks on critical
infrastructure and residential areas
ukrainians must be allowed to seek
safely safety wherever they choose
president as USG Griffiths made clear
the impact of Russia's actions are still
being felt around the world
commodity prices are up and 345 million
people face crisis levels of food
insecurity
with close to 50 million one step away
from famine
this is the global cost of Russia's
actions
the United Kingdom strongly supports the
efforts of the UN in partnership with
Tokyo to continue bringing Ukrainian
grain to World Markets
the Black Sea grain initiative is vital
the world needs Ukrainian grain
so everything should be done to tackle
Global Food insecurity and ensure food
assistance reaches those who need it
most
we call on Russia to respect the terms
of the deal and the latest 120-day
extension
finally president
the United Kingdom is fully committed to
holding Russia to account for its legal
actions in Ukraine
the international criminal courts
announcement today is an important step
for ensuring those responsible are held
accountable
barbaric atrocities have been committed
during this conflict including against
children
it is right they should be independent
independently investigated and those
accountable face Justice
thank you
I thank the representative
of the United Kingdom
for their statement
I give the floor
to the representative of the United
States
thank you Mr President and thank you
under Secretary General Griffiths for
your thorough briefing and for the un's
efforts to secure an extension of the
Black Sea grain initiative
colleagues as under Secretary General
Griffiths clearly Contin outline as long
as Russia's continues to blockade
Ukraine's ports the world needs the
Black Sea Green initiative the Black Sea
grain initiative slashes Global food
prices it comes Market volatility it
ameliorates Global Food security it
saves lives it must continue reliably
and sustainably
the initiative must be allowed to
operate efficiently it must work at a
pace that meets Global demand the delays
imposed by Russia have already reduced
the number of ships leaving port and
increased Transportation costs we agree
with what the Secretary General said
during his visit to Kiev two weeks ago
the initiative should enable the
greatest possible use of Black Sea
export infrastructure right now only
three ports are free to operate while
Global food prices remain at historic
highs Ukraine's food exports are down by
more than one-third from last year
Russia's war of aggression on Ukraine
has already disrupted the global food
supply chain and caused a spike in food
prices pushing many more into extreme
poverty
the world needs this green it must flow
freely since the beginning of the
initiative more than 24 million metric
tons of brain and all seeds have been
shipped worldwide including humanitarian
Aid through the world food program for
the world's most food insecure people
during his trip to Africa this past week
secretary blinken saw bags of wheat
gifts from the Ukrainian people that had
been delivered to Ethiopia because of
the Black Sea grain initiative this is
grain that can feed the world this is
the critical assistance that it is that
is at stake we know and the rest of the
world knows that Russia exports of food
are at least as high as their pre-war
levels when we hear the Russian
government say they're being held back
from exporting grain from exporting
fertilizer the numbers show it's just
not true and when it comes to sanctions
we have gone to extraordinary links to
communicate the clear call outs for food
and fertilizers to governments and to
the private sector simply put sanctions
are not the issue Beyond the Black Sea
grain initiative the council must also
focus on the continuing Devastation and
dire humanitarian needs caused by
Russia's war in Ukraine on February 15th
the U.N announced the U.N that U.N
agencies and ngos will need 3.9 billion
dollars to bring humanitarian Aid to
those inside of Ukraine
that doesn't include the additional 1.7
billion dollars to support countries
hosting millions of Ukrainian refugees
for our part since the Invasion the
United States has provided nearly 2
billion in humanitarian assistance to
those in need in Ukraine and the region
and we have provided nearly 15.5 billion
dollars in direct budget support to the
government of Ukraine through World Bank
mechanisms we plan to provide an
additional 7.4 billion dollars through
September we're doing our part and we're
asking the rest of the International
Community to do theirs we should all dig
deep and we must do so without
sacrificing a single Cent to the many
other urgent humanitarian crises around
the world funding alone however is not
enough Security Council Members must
continue to demand unhindered
humanitarian access across Ukraine just
as 141 member states did last month
and we must call out Russia's continued
missile and drone attacks on civilians
and critical infrastructure and how
these attacks are preventing
humanitarian assistance from reaching
areas areas temporarily occupied by
Russia just last week massive attacks
destroyed residential buildings
electricity infrastructure and Railways
killing at least 11 civilians this was
also the 16th major attack on Ukraine's
energy infrastructure in the last five
months showing flagrant disregard for
nuclear safety Russia's attacks have
even resulted in deaths and injuries of
humanitarian workers and in particular
women and girls have faced scary
dramatic increases in trafficking and
gender-based violence as they have tried
to flee for their lives today as we wrap
up the commission on the status of women
let us all commit to holding Russia's
forces accountable for these atrocities
colleagues there is of course of course
one way to instantly prevent further
suffering Russia can heed the demands of
the U.N and the world's member states to
withdraw immediately completely and
uncondition unconditionally from Ukraine
until then let us do everything we can
to help the people of Ukraine and all
those hurt by The Fallout of this
horrific unnecessary War thank you Mr
President
I thank the representative
of the United States
for their important statement
I now give the flow to the
representative of Gabon
let's see thank you Mr President
I thank the under Secretary General
Martin Griffiths for his enlightening
briefing
a a year of destructive Warfare has
already elapsed and no solution to the
crisis is emerging on the horizon quite
on the contrary the escalation is
continuing and is becoming ever more
widespread on land and in the air after
a year the cost of the war in terms of
human and material losses increases
every day and continues to worsen the
economic situation in Ukraine and to
render the prospect for Ukraine's
reconstruction ever dimmer the
humanitarian situation as a consequence
is constantly deteriorating
civilians and civilian infrastructure
continue to be the targets of Relentless
shelling and large-scale shelling indeed
no area is spared by the parties no area
is spared and parties don't hesitate to
Target energy infrastructure
energy infrastructure which for some
time has been the favorite Target of all
sorts of maneuvers
in recent days increasing tensions
around the nuclear power plant in
separation point to the fact that the
risk of a nuclear accident remains a
possibility which cannot be ruled out we
reiterate the fact that access to water
energy and other essential Public
Services must
not be subject to any black male
whatsoever
my country reiterates its condemnation
of attacks against civilians and
civilian infrastructure
all forms of attacks targeting innocent
people and in particular women and
children are also condemned buyers and
we remind warring parties of their
obligations
pursuant to International humanitarian
law even in times of War
human rights must be preserved Mr
President the meetings of this Council
must focus on the search for a solution
for the victims of the war in Ukraine
for more than 8 million refugees 5
million internally displaced persons and
more than 17 million ukrainians
humanitarian Aid must be found prospects
for the future must be offered to
Ukraine's young people as well as to
displace families and to the thousands
of children whose lives and education
have been turned uptight upside down it
is patently clear that the war is
dragging on
moreover disastrous International
consequences are clear in terms of price
spikes of consumer goods
certain countries have seen waves of
protests and flare-ups in response to
Rising costs of living and shrinking
purchasing power which have gone hand in
hand with
rampant inflation we call upon parties
to renew the Black Sea grain initiatives
for the period of time provided for by
the initial agreement and we express our
support for the facilitators for their
constant engagement we welcome and
encourage all efforts designed to lift
all obstacles to the full and complete
implementation of the agreement for the
benefit of all parties we have taken
note of the recent unktad report and of
the fao's assessment regarding
grain exports headed to developing
countries and their effects on the
global grain price index index the
conclusion of the bsgi remains a glimmer
of hope and a potential anchor to which
broader initiatives can cling broader
initiatives that is likely to forge a
path towards the cessation of
hostilities we will continue to urge all
parties to preserve this a key Mr
President I reiterate my country's
repudiation of war and of all the all
use of weapons of mass destruction of
the use of all
weapon methods of warfare designed to
spread fear and to cause pointless
suffering to civilians my country
expresses its support for and
encouragement to humanitarian Personnel
working in combat zones and in the
country's hosting refugees for their
remarkable work and their tireless
efforts to bring a little bit of
humanity back to the daily lives of
those who as a result of War have lost
all sense of orientation we calls upon
call upon all parties to commit to Peace
by way of a candid and direct dialogue
parties must refrain from using
unilateral actions likely to shrink
negotiation Windows my country continues
to believe that the only solution is a
political one and that peaceful
coexistence is the ultimate goal to
reach thank you I think
the representative
of Gabon
for their statement
I shall now make a statement
in my capacity as the representative of
Mozambique
I begin by thanking
ESG Griffith for his important briefing
I wish to recognize
the presence in this room
of the distinguished permanent
representatives of Denmark
Lithuania Ukraine
and the European Union
a distinguished council members
as we entered the second year
of the Russia Ukraine conflict
the humanitarian toll keeps mounting
the prospect for peace keep receding
and the resources needed to alleviate
the human suffering Cape multiplying
Mozambique strongly believes that the
best and the most effective support
the concept can land
to the humanitarian efforts in Ukraine
is by stepping up
efforts to bring this conflict
to an end
our own experience in Mozambique
shows that there is no humanitarian
solutions to the humanitarian problems
only
political negotiated Solutions can solve
humanitarian problems
Mozambique notes however that
notwithstanding our repeated calls for
dialogue and appeals to the parties to
return to the negotiating table
a little or no progress has been
registered in the direction of peace
nor have been heeded
our repeated warnings about the
increasing spillover effects of the
conflict toward the parts of the world
as well as the ever-present danger of
strategic miscalculation
we have said that the conflict
is constraining the ability of the
humanitarian Community to master an
appropriate and rapid response to other
challenges
throughout the globe be it in earthquake
in turkey or a cyclone affecting
countries like Mozambique Malawi and
Madagascar
we welcome The Good Will expressed by
some members of the International
Community to facilitate mediate
and promote peace initiatives with the
consent of all parties and in good faith
we have argued on several occasions
for the parties to seize and build upon
the few signs of Goodwill shown during
the conflict such as prisoner exchanges
and the Black Sea grain initiative to
discolorate
the conflict
however we must concede with realism
that the more than 22 Council meetings
dedicated to Ukraine alone since 2022
the multiple warnings and offers of
mediation have so far not yielded any
positive and concrete momentum towards
peace
distinguished council members
it is high time for us to redouble our
efforts towards concreting pragmatic
steps to end this conflict
while incrementing the humanitarian
assistance
the Black Sea grain initiative
ly described by Mr Griffith as a Beacon
of Hope against a bleak backdrop and in
our view a rare bright stop of
multilateral diplomacy expires
tomorrow and we hope it will extended
fourth width
as the U.N Secretary General stressed
recently
we must do everything possible
to preserve the Integrity of the Black
Sea grain initiative and ensure its
continuity this is in the interest of
the Ukraine Ukrainian people and of the
World At Large
we urge once again
all involved parties to set aside their
differences and allow the extension and
possibly the indefinite rollout of these
life-saving Arrangement essential for
countries such as mind who are already
dealing with acute and imminent threats
to food security
believes
that the unity of the Council on this
issue is essential I thank you
I now resume my function as president of
the council
[Applause]
I now give the flow to the
representative of Ukraine
is present
distinguished members of Security
Council under Secretary General Griffis
I command the security Council for
upholding multiple General Assembly
resolutions
on Ukraine's territorial integrity
by not allowing the Russian citizen
so-called ombuds person
of a part of Ukraine's the next region
that Russia tried to Annex
to address these body
we thank under Secretary General
Griffiths for his briefing
which highlighted once again the
devastating humanitarian impact of the
Russian aggression
we command the U.N efforts for a
Resolute humanitarian response in my
country
U.N LED operations provide a Lifeline
for millions of ukrainians affected by
Russia's war of aggression against
Ukraine
we also appreciate that the Secretary
General while visiting Kiev on the 8th
of March
clearly confirmed the U.N commitment to
work hard to mitigate the impacts will
until a just peace can be attained
a jazz piece that according to the
Secretary General
would mean that the sovereignty
Independence and integrity of Ukraine
must be upheld within is recognized
International borders
established at Independence in 1991.
should it be a surprise that Russia
responded to this visit in the same way
as it did on the previous occasions when
the Secretary General was in Kiev
with missile shelling
81 missiles of various types were
launched to kill ukrainians and to
destroy civilian infrastructure
immediately upon the visit of the
Secretary General
it was the 15th massive missile strike
since last October when destruction of
Civilian infrastructure in particular
energy facilities was publicly declared
by Russia as a method of warfare
as a result of the missile Terror which
peaked in the winter season Ukraine has
temporarily lost 44 percent of its
nuclear generation
75 percent of thermal power plant
capacity and 33 percent of combined heat
and power plants
Russia however has failed to put Ukraine
on its knees by terrorizing it with
missiles
as it is also failing on the battlefield
by burning more and more regular
military units and Wagner mercenaries
near the town of bakmut
this irrational enmity towards Ukraine
and ukrainians keeps the peace efforts
in stalemate
Russia continues to ignore the will of
the U.N General Assembly
expressed in each resolution
principles of the U.N Charter underlying
a comprehensive just and Lasting peace
in Ukraine
Russia rejects the peace formula Plan
offered by President of Ukraine
which follows the same logic as the
anger resolution
instead Russia persists in its
warmongering rhetoric and through
Putin's spokesperson
threatens that we will continue to
achieve his goals and that I quote now
it is possible only only by military
means end of quote
the report of the independent
International Commission of inquiry on
Ukraine
released yesterday provides us with a
shocking record of crimes that might
seem unbelievable in the 21st century
examples of the commission's findings
and I need to remind all of us and those
who listen to us that it is not the
government's finding it is the UN
findings
and I quote
rapes were committed
at gunpoint
with extreme brutality and with acts of
torture
such as beatings and strangling
perpetrators at times threatened to kill
the victim or her family
if she resisted
in some cases more than one soldier
raped the same victim
or rape of the same victim was committed
several times
in one incident the victim was pregnant
and begged in vain
the soldiers to spare her
she had a miscarriage a few days later
perpetrators also in some instances
executed or tortured husbands and other
male relatives
family members including children
were sometimes forced to watch
perpetrators rape their loved ones end
of quote
among other facts established by the
United Nations I quote
detention interrogation torture or ill
treatment often preceded execution
some victims were found with hands or
feed tied
according to medical records and
photographs the most common method of
killing was a gunshot to the Head At
Close Range
end of quote
highlighting the issue of force
transfers and deputations of children
the U.N commission stated that I quote
the owners to trace and find parents or
family members
fell primarily on the children
parents and relatives encountered
considerable logistical financial and
security challenges in retrieving their
children
in some cases it took weeks or months
for families to be reunited
Witnesses told the commission
that many of the smaller children
transferred have not been able to
establish contact with their families
and might as a consequence lose contact
with them indefinitely end of quote
we welcome that today the ICC issued
warrants of arrest for two individuals
who are allegedly responsible for the
war crime of unlawful deportation of
population children
and that of unlawful transfer of
population children from occupied areas
of Ukraine to the Russian Federation
there are reasonable grounds to believe
that these persons bear individual crank
criminal responsibility for their
aforementioned crimes
their names are Vladimir Putin the
president of the Russian Federation and
Maria levova biloba so-called
commissioner for children rights in the
Office of the President of the Russian
Federation
this step testifies again that the
process of ensuring Justice is going on
and sooner or later it will end with
putting Libor belova and other war
criminals in the docks
Mr President Russia's War has taken a
terrible human toll
leaving tens of thousands of civilians
killed injured or maimed
the tactics of Siege
and scorched Earth employed by Russia
have resulted in the destruction of some
59 000 residential buildings
436 hospitals and over 2200
2.2 000 educational institutions
these numbers do not include the
temporarily occupied areas
in which the real level of Destruction
is much higher
as Russia's attacks are mounting
17.6 million ukrainians or about 40
percent of the population remain in dire
need of humanitarian assistance
Mr President the increasing level of
land mine contamination of Ukraine
constitutes another grave threat for the
people of Ukraine
the Russian war of aggression has turned
Ukraine into one of the most mine
contaminated countries in the world
in total according to the state
emergency service of Ukraine the
territory of Ukraine that is considered
to be contaminated is about 174
000 square kilometers or 30 percent of
the entire territory of our country
the Russian forces in Ukraine widely use
entire Personnel landmines and cluster
Munitions that they planned ma that they
planned mines on civilians rules
Pathways residential areas and
agricultural fields
nearly 50 000 square kilometers of
agricultural land are currently
unsuitable for use due to the mines and
explosive hazards or armed hostilities
even under these extraordinary
circumstances Ukraine has fulfilled its
obligations for the grain expert
initiative which alleviates the food
crisis in the world and prevents many
new crises around the world
since August the 1st last year
814 vessels have have exported
24.4 million tones of Ukrainian food
from the pores of Odessa to Asia Europe
and Africa within the framework of the
Black Sea grain initiative
this volume could have been
significantly higher if it was not
Russia's policy of delaying the
inspection of vessels
due to the storage of the new Fleet
sorry
due to the shortage of the new fleets
and the few in the territorial Waters of
turkey the expert of foodstuff by the
grain Corridor does not exceed 3.4
million tons per month
this is despite the ability to give the
world 6 million tones of Ukrainian
agricultural products
for example only 149 inspections were
carried out in February despite the the
being 296 inspections planned for this
month
in addition as a result of these actions
there are constant views of vessels from
120 to 140 vessels and Ukrainian ports
face the problem of a shortage of new
fleets for loading
today 86 vessels that are being sent for
loading are awaiting inspection in
Turkish territorial Waters
the Black Sea grain initiative should be
renewed after it expires on the 18th of
March for at least
120 days as it is foreseen or for an
unlimited period
his coverage should be expanded to
Ukrainian posts in the nikolaev region
today more than 30 countries and the EU
joined the grain from Ukraine
humanitarian program launched by
president zielinski to help the poorest
countries of the world with food
the program raised almost 200 million
dollars and and sent more than 140 000
tons of Ukrainian grain to countries
suffering from Hunger
we call all countries around the world
who wish to make their contribution to
Global Food security to join this
initiative
excellencies yesterday Ukraine paid
tribute to the victims of one of the
most horrendous Russian war crimes
a year ago Russian air bombs destroyed a
theater in mariopal a building that was
being used as a shelter and was clearly
identified with the sign children
we still do not know the exact number of
victims and Russia did its utmost to mop
up the traces of his crime as soon as
Mario upo was occupied
every day of the war every day of the
Russian prisons in Ukraine multiplies
the sufferings of Ukrainian people
the war must be brought to an end
followed by accountability for the
aggressor
we appreciate the strong stance of the
International Community to strive for a
comprehensive just and Lasting peace
that will be based on the principles of
the UN Charter
this is the approach that Ukraine is
ready to implement and that all peace
efforts and proposals should be based on
we urge the UN member states to
contribute to the implementations of the
general assemblies resolution of 23rd
February this year
this should include stepping up our
pressure on the Russian Federation to
give up its aggressive cause
until it happens Ukraine will continue
to defend itself to defend the
principles and the rules based order I
thank you
I think the representative of Ukraine
for their statement
I now give the floor to his Excellency
Mr Olive
head of the delegation of the European
Union to the United Nations
good afternoon Mr President thank you
very much I would like to say a few
words on behalf of the European Union
and its member states and the candidate
country's North Macedonia Montenegro
Albania Ukraine Republic of Moldova and
Bosnia Herzegovina the potential
candidate country Georgia as well as
Andorra they align themselves with this
statement
Mr President for over a year now Russia
has been struggling to find any
justification whatsoever for its war of
aggression against Ukraine
we are well aware that all that Russia's
escalating aggression has with daily
missile strikes that are costing
innocent lives of the people of Ukraine
we've just heard living examples of that
from the ambassador of Ukraine and for
many of you around the table
and while the world is suffering from
soaring food prices Russia's War
continues to hamper efforts to export
Ukrainian grains this must end
I will emphasize three points in my
intervention one the global consequences
of Russia's full-scale Invasion to its
systematic attacks against civilians and
critical infrastructure and three the
need for a comprehensive just and
Lasting peace
first the war has disrupted agricultural
production and trade and driven world
food and fertilizer prices to
unprecedented levels we must all work
together to address these serious
consequences and we welcome the sector
General's engagement in this regard
we Echo The Plea made by 14 members
around this Council this afternoon that
the Black Sea grain initiative is
renewed to provide the continuity and
predictability needed by operators and
to avoid discontinuation in shipments of
grain to developing countries
the Black Sea grain initiative has been
instrumental in bringing down Global
food prices and it needs to run at its
full potential
in addition to the Black Sea grain
initiative Mr President the EU
solidarity Lanes have allowed the export
of more than 29 million tons of
Ukraine's food and agricultural Goods to
the world
food program chartered vessels have
transported over 480 000 metric tons of
wheat through various Black Sea ports
including to Ethiopia Afghanistan Yemen
Somalia and Kenya Ukraine is also
helping the ones in need despite the
efforts of the war on its population
through the grain from Ukraine program
175 000 metric tons of grain have been
donated to countries in need many EU
member states are proud to be part of
this Ukrainian initiative
so let's be absolutely clear that it's
Russia's war that has rocked the markets
Russia's fertilizer exports are exempt
from EU sanctions U.N data clearly
demonstrate that total exports of
Russian fertilizers to developing
countries remain stable in volume in
2022 compared with previous years
moreover Russian revenue from fertilizer
exports jumped by 70 percent in the
first 10 months of last year compared to
the same period in 2021 according to
data from the UN food and agriculture
organization
Russia conveniently omits to mention its
own export taxes and quota on both
serial serials and fertilizers these
lead to artificial increases in global
prices and the profits of Russian
companies at the expense of those most
in need
Mr President at a time of unprecedented
humanitarian needs the EU not only
supports ukrainians but remains
collectively among the largest donors of
the humanitarian Aid globally we're
grateful to all countries who are
generously supporting those in need in
Ukraine and elsewhere and we encourage
all to step up their assistance in line
with Archer's appeal for aid for this
year
I want to make one thing absolutely
clear here the EU humanitarian funding
allocated to Ukraine does not come at
the expense of other humanitarian needs
worldwide and they have been eloquently
described by Martin Griffiths earlier
today and I want to state that EU
remains consistently at the Forefront of
those needs
second Mr President yesterday the U.N
independent Commission of inquiries set
up the human rights by the Human Rights
Council concluded as we've heard that
Russia has committed numerous violations
of international human rights law and
international humanitarian law in
addition to a wide range of war crimes
the findings are shocking including
sexual violence forced deportations
torture and other forms of inhumane and
degrading treatment as a tactic of War
we've heard of the cases of rape just
now
we continue to be appalled by Russia's
continued systematic and indiscriminate
attacks on civilians and critical
infrastructure and we condemn them in
the strongest possible terms
Russia's shelling is killing civilians
and depriving them of electricity
Heating and water during winter they
accumulated damage to the energy system
and the consequent difficulties in
excessive electricity and heating
services are exacerbating the
humanitarian situation
Mr President many of Ukraine's cities
have been bombarded into ruins and we
just heard the Russian Ambassador say
that they use only High Precision
weaponry
now this would seem like a confession
that that destruction is intentional and
deliberate
we welcome that following the journal
assembly's adoption of the resolution on
the registry of damage all such such
acts committed by Russia in Ukraine will
be thoroughly registered
we're also extremely concerned by the
Russian offensive against bakmut we note
that this military operation is led by
the infamous Wagner group known for its
abuses and serious violations for human
rights and humanitarian law not just in
Ukraine recall once again the importance
of upholding human rights in
international humanitarian law and that
all commanders perpetrators and
accomplices of war crimes and other most
serious crimes committed in connection
with Russia's war of aggression against
Ukraine are held to account
Russia must also enable safe rapid and
unimpeded humanitarian access into the
temporarily occupied territories through
the front lines
on March 9 the saparichia nuclear power
plant was again cut off from Ukraine's
power grid for several hours and cooling
depended solely on diesel generators
this was the sixth time since the start
of the war the head of the international
atomic energy agency issued a warning
about Safety and Security at the plant
this is extremely worrying for all of us
the EU fully supports the un's work to
assist Ukraine in ensuring nuclear
Safety and Security and to maintain the
implementation of the safeguards
pursuant to Ukraine's obligations
finally Mr President colleagues we
reiterate a call for comprehensive just
and Lasting peace in line with the
resolution adopted by the general
assembly on the 23rd of February with
support of an overwhelming majority of
Union member states we express our
support for the peace formula of
President zielinski and we reaffirm our
commitment to work actively with Ukraine
on the 10 point peace ban it's clear
that the large majority of the U.N
membership including the members of this
Council remain committed to peace in
line with the U.N Charter but while
while the general assembly once again
called for a peaceful long-term solution
based on the U.N Charter in respect of
Ukraine's sovereignty and territorial
Integrity Russia continues as in
actually stepping up it's offensive
we Retreat or call on Russia to
immediately cease all hostilities and
unconditionally completely and
immediately withdraw all its forces and
military equipment from the entire
territory of Ukraine within its
internationally recognized borders while
Russia's War lasts the European Union
will remain steadfast in our support to
the people of Ukraine for as long as it
takes I thank you very much Mr President
I thank his Excellency Mr skog for his
statement
I now give the floor
to the representative of Denmark
Mr President I thank under Secretary
General uh Griffiths for his briefing I
have the honor to speak on behalf of the
five Nordic countries Finland Iceland
Norway Sweden and of course my own
country Denmark Mr President allow me
first to express our condolences for the
devastation caused by Cyclone Freddie to
those affected in Mozambique as well as
in Malawi and Madagascar
we stand with you in solidarity as we
stand with the people of Ukraine
Mr President last month an overwhelming
majority of member states from all
regions of the world adopted a
resolution for peace in Ukraine
and once again demanded that Russia
immediately completely and
unconditionally withdraw from the
territory of Ukraine
the general assembly underscored the
need to reach as soon as possible a
comprehensive just and Lasting peace in
line with the principles of the U.N
Charter and we reaffirmed our commitment
to the sovereignty Independence unity
and territorial Integrity of Ukraine
within its internationally recognized
borders
president the nordics would like to
highlight the following three areas of
concern first the disruptive Global
consequences of Russia's war of
aggression and the importance of the
continuation of the Black Sea grain
Initiative for Global Food security
second Russia's ongoing violations of
international law and the obligation to
provide full safe and unhindered access
for humanitarian access and three the
impacts of conflict-related sexual and
gender-based violence
Russia's illegal Invasion has not only
had shattering consequences for the
people of Ukraine it has also worsened
the humanitarian situation globally
Russia's war of aggression has hampered
Ukraine's ability to produce and Export
grain and other agricultural products
that are much needed in communities
around the world
we the nordics are determined to be at
the Forefront of mitigating the
disruptive Global consequences of the
war
we have continued our efforts to assist
where the needs are greatest
this includes countries in Africa where
existing food insecurity has been made
worse by the decline in export from
Ukraine
the continuation of the Black Sea grain
initiative is imperative to mitigating
the food insecurity caused by Russia's
war against Ukraine especially in
developing countries
the initiative has ensured exports of
more than 24 million tons of grain and
other food stuff from Ukraine since
August last year it has helped stabilize
Global Food Markets and food prices and
it has ensured delivery of food to
countries in need we urge Russia to be
part of a solution to ensure 120-day
rollover of the Black Sea grain
initiative in line with the Istanbul
agreement
in Ukraine the violence and destruction
shows no sign of a beating Russia has
resumed its deadly and destructive
missile attacks the latest report by the
U.N independent Commission of inquiry
published yesterday concludes that
Russia has committed numerous violations
of international human rights law and
international human insurance law in
addition to a wines rate of war crimes
the findings are shocking including
sexual violence torture as well as the
forced transplant deportation of
children from buchane Ukraine and their
illegal adoptions in Russia such acts
are violation of international
humanitarian law and may amount to war
crimes
the commission has further documented
indiscriminate and disproportionate
attacks in populated areas causing
excessive suffering and harm to
civilians and civilian objects including
hospitals and schools
Russia's attacks on civilian
infrastructure including the systematic
targeting of energy related
infrastructure May amount to crimes
against humanity
and this is real and for instance it
means that pregnant women are denied
prenatal care and forced to give birth
under dangerous circumstances we call on
all parties to protect health care and
the provision of reproductive Health
Services not only in accordance with
International humanitarian law but as a
basic human right
the need to ensure protection for all
civilians is a key humanitarian
prerogative however Russia continues to
violate our agreed norms and rules of
armed conflict we call on all parties to
comply with their obligations on the
international law and to protect
civilians and civilian infrastructure as
well as to enable full safe and
unhindered access for humanitarian
actors
lastly Mr president we'd like to draw
attention to the alarming reports of
sexual and gender-based violence in
Ukraine the violence is perpetrated
overwhelmingly by Russian military
personnel on Ukraine women girls men and
boys
conflict-related sexual violence is a
clear violation of international
humanitarian law and international human
rights law and may constitute war crimes
and crimes against humanity
Mr President we must listen to the
survivors of violence and they demand
justice but also dignity and support to
continue their lives investing in the
mental health and psychosocial
well-being of survivors is not only an
investment in their recovery but also an
investment in sustainable peace and
National resilience
Mr President to conclude let me State
the nordics will continue to stand with
Ukraine and its people and we commend
Ukraine's Initiative for a just peace
and we support the various initiatives
established to secure accountability for
atrocity crimes committed in Ukraine I
thank you
I thank the representative
of Denmark
for his
statement
on behalf of the naughty countries
and I in my
capacity as representative of Mozambique
I also wish to thank you
for the expression of solidarity
towards the people of Mozambique Malawi
and Madagascar
I now give the flow
to the representative of Lithuania
Mr President
um